I'm gonna put mm let's call this you
know 500 500 1000 1500 let's make this
top spot here
mm it's almost like I planned the size
of this graph so that it would fit
appropriately now if I make that mm up
there right I'm going to switch over to
blue now what you guys have told me is
that the gradient of that graph above is
2004 that early portion of the graph up
to a day 68 and then it stops okay so
I'm gonna go ahead and I'm going to draw
my gradient line here and it has a value
of 2,000 indicating that for all those
days from the start of my my graph
they're up to day 68 I'm increasing my
number of new cases at a rate of 2,000
every single day which which is a lot
right okay so at that point I actually
have to pause because looking back at
the original graph let's come back to
that now the gradient then changes right
it starts to shallow out now again I've
put a grid here and hopefully the
numbers can help you interpret what's
going on here as I go by day by day by
day the gradient now is a different
number have a look from day 68 to 71 and
beyond what's the rate of change now
what's the gradient functions value
going to be anyone want to throw in a
comment aha okay very good
mo gets in first Jana all right Lawrence
Oh everyone's coming in there okay it's
great all right except Abbie I think we
threw an extra zero in there I hope it
doesn't get that bad but I think I know
what's your event so yeah there's a
lower gradient of a thousand so it's
actually half right now what does that
mean on the graph of the gradient
function that we were doing down below
well I'm not going to be at 2,000
anymore it just abruptly in this model
anyway it abruptly drops down to 1000
and it continues so let's go to our
green graph over here it kind of has
this break in time like so and I'm a
thousand is going to be here on my
vertical scale so from day 68 onwards
I'm going to have let's go and blue now
I'm gonna have a gradient of 1,000 there
we go that's what the shape of the graph
is now this is a weird looking graph we
call it a step function because it looks
like a set of steps an opportunity to
know the technical name but this thing's
weird it's it's sort of broken into
pieces but we can still understand it
and importantly we can still answer that
original question from this different
perspective of a derivative and let me
just repeat that again we're going to go
back to this original question what's
the total number of new cases between
days 67 and day 71 we can answer that
same question on the basis of this new
graph just imagine just forget about
that earlier graph that we did before
suppose this was the only graph that was
presented to you how would you work out
that same number well if you want to
work out how many new cases there have
been over that time you would do this in
chunks right you'd say well from day 67
today 68 that's this sort of time period
here there's a single day that passes
and during that day 2,000 people are
diagnosed so let's do some working here
if I said the total number of new cases
I should say new cases sorry I said it
but I forgot to write it the total
number of new cases well for starters
there's going to be that one day where
2,000 people are diagnosed that's from
day 67 going over today 68 but then
there's this new part of it right as I
go from day 68 to 71 across here and
then I stop this where my hair is gone
czar slightly too far here I've got
three days that pass and then there's a
new rate at which new cases are
diagnosed three days and each day just
like you told me there's a thousand new
cases diagnosed so I'm going to add on
to that one lot of two thousand one day
with two thousand cases per day I'm now
going to add on to that an extra
three days where I get 1,000 cases per
day I've still got the same units there
I'm gonna cheat a little bit and be lazy
sorry guys okay there we go
so I've got three days they're at a
slower rate and so thankfully hopefully
things will improve from here now the
numbers again like before are simple
right one a lot of mm gives me two
thousand three lots and 1000 give me
three thousand and much to our relief
this is exactly the same answer that we
got before in mathematics if we approach
a problem from a different way we should
expect to get a different answer we
should expect to confirm the previous
answer that we got okay now what does
this tell us
what can we learn from looking at the
same situation total number of new cases
between this particular time period and
looking at it from two different
perspectives initially we looked at it
from a sort of total accumulative sense
and we did this subtraction and then
here what we did was we had a look at it
from the perspective of the derivative
from the perspective of the rate of
change what this tells us is that really
these two things are one and the same if
I only gave you this derivative graph
you could work it out by saying oh one
times two thousand actually represents
I'm going to draw a rectangle in here
this area at the top right that's the
one which is the width and the two
thousand which is the height and then in
addition to that I also have this other
guy over here another rectangle which is
three wide and it's 1,000 tall I'm
calculating like we looked at last
lesson the area under the curve now in
this case the area under the curve is
really easy to work with because they're
nice regular shapes they rectangles the
easiest kind of shape to evaluate the
area of but often in fact for years now
we've been dealing with functions that
don't have nice neat curves like this
they're all Wiggly and wobbly and we
don't have nice like length times
breadth or base times height on two for
those triangles we're having a look at
last time we've got really complicated
shapes that we don't simply have a
formula for so in those cases if I asked
you for the area under the curve of a
graph like that
how would we do that in the absence of
an area formula like we learned in year
7 and 8 and the answer is by having a
look at where we started by going up
instead of going from this graph and
then differentiating to go down we know
that there are less of that process is
what we call integration right
anti-differentiation if you might
remember that's how we first introduced
it so if you've got this weird wobbly
looking curve that it's difficult to
work out the area of you can't just
break it into neat and easy rectangles
like this then instead of trying to
break it into such areas you integrate
that will take you to this curve and
then you simply take the difference
between one value and another you'll end
up with this same solution so underneath
where you've put those two graphs let's
try and capture what we've just said in
some of the notation that we've already
been using okay
underneath here what does this tell us
about the connections between everything
well I was interested remember in total
change that was the question I was
asking about these covert 19 cases and
we looked at it in two different ways
the first way was to say well just have
a look at where you ended and subtract
that from where you started so if I have
a think over here let's call this guy f
of X capital F 11,000 and 6,000 where
did I get those numbers from and the
answer is I looked at the horizontal
axis I looked at the appropriate days 67
and 71 and then I went up to the graph
to see where that matched right in other
words that are 11,000 was really F of 71
that's where I got that value from and
the 6000 was really F of 67 that's where
I read it off of the graph I got those
vertical values so now I can take that
together and write well the first way
that we calculated this was look at your
state at the end and subtract that from
your state at the beginning you'll work
out the difference and you'll get your
answer which we worked out was 5000 but
you can equivalently look at it from the
perspective of a rate of change that was
the second graph I'm going to use some
colors here to help me
a rate of change and then you multiply
that by how much time you spend at that
particular rate so for example we had a
rate of 2,000 per day for one day and we
multiply that together and we included
that with a rate of change of 1000 per
day for three days and we did that over
and over again
now to say that to say we would do that
over and over again for all the
different parts of our graph we use this
notation that we introduced before this
elongated s we're taking the sum of all
of those different areas in our case it
was pretty easy just two rectangles from
67 to 71 of number one our function
which is the rate of change that's why
I'm using these two colors here to
separate them and then our time was on
the horizontal axis remember that so the
change in time we would use the letter D
to indicate change like Delta and
because it's on the horizontal axis we
would say well that's that's an x value
right so this is the familiar kind of
notation that you've been seeing for a
while in differential and integral
calculus now all of this is particular
to this specific example day 67 day 71
and those values of 11,000 and 6,000 but
this whole idea of looking at a function
looking at its integral to working out
to work out area this is always true no
matter what numbers you throw at it and
that's what the fundamental theorem of
calculus I'm just going to write F T C
because those words are too long for me
to write the fundamental theorem of
calculus tells us this right if we want
to work out the sum of all the areas
from some starting point to some ending
point a and B and we have some function
f of X and we're having a look at it
horizontally okay if we had nice you
know straight lines we could just go
ahead and say all that bits a rectangle
that bits a triangle that bits a
trapezium and then off we go but in the
vast majority of cases we don't have a
nice neat formula we need to resort to
calculus you need to take this f of X
you need to anti-differentiate it to
integrate it to go up to the function
that it came from and then subtract
your end point from your start point
this guy here if you want to this is the
kind of thing that you want to put a big
box around this is the fundamental
theorem of calculus so this guy here
whoops there we go this guy here is what
we're going to use in a sense just like
you learned how to do differentiation
with first principles right this is kind
of like your first principles for
integration this is gonna be thing the
thing we come back to you over and over
again to solve problems just like first
principles helped us get gradients